♪ ♪
>> Sean: BARACK OBAMA TONIGHT
BEING FORCED TO DEFEND HIMSELF
AGAINST ALLEGATIONS THAT HIS
SOUTHSIDE CHICAGO PRESIDENTIAL
CENTER WILL "GENTRIFIED" THE
NEIGHBORHOOD, RAISE PRICES,
DRIVE POOR FAMILIES FROM THE
AREA.
I DON'T KNOW, MAYBE IT'S LIKE
OBAMA DISNEY.
HERE'S HIS RESPONSE.
>> THE TRUTH IS ANY TIME YOU DO
A BIG PROJECT IS ALWAYS GOING TO
BE SOME PEOPLE WHO SAY, WELL,
LOOK, WE DON'T WANT CHANGE,
WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT IT, WE DON'T
KNOW HOW IT'S GOING TO TURN OUT,
WHICH IS WHY WE'VE GONE THROUGH
SUCH AN EXHAUSTIVE PROCESS TO
ENCOURAGE AND ELICIT COMMENTS
AND CONCERNS AND CRITICISM AND
SUGGESTIONS FROM THE COMMUNITY.
>> Sean: HERE FOR REACTION,
GEORGIA SENATE CANDIDATE
HERSCHEL WALKER ALONG WITH
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
LEO TERRELL.
IF I DON'T REALLY UNDERSTAND IT.
I'M ALL FOR -- I COULDN'T
UNDERSTAND OCASIO-CORTEZ, THE
REAL SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE,
HERSCHEL WALKER, WHEN AMAZON
WANTED TO GREET THESE JOBS IN
HER DISTRICT, I WOULD BE LIKE
ALL OVER THAT.
WHY DIDN'T SHE ALLOW THAT?
I WANT TO SEE, YOU KNOW, AREAS
IN CHICAGO GET INVESTMENT MONEY.
THIS WILL BE LIKE DISNEY, OBAMA
DISNEY.
YOU GET TO SEE EVERYTHING OBAMA.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES,
SEAN, YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO MAKE
SOME UNHAPPY.
THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY THAT THE
OBAMA'S HAVE TO EMPOWER THE
COMMUNITY, SO PEOPLE SHOULD BE
APPLAUDING IT RATHER THAN MAKING
FUN OF IT, OR THEY SHOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING THAT'S
VERY GREAT THERE THAT
MAYOR LIGHTFOOT WENT FROM
DEFUNDING THE POLICE TO FUNDING
THE POLICE BECAUSE RIGHT NOW,
WHAT OBAMA IS TALKING ABOUT IS
GIVING PEOPLE JOBS, BUT I THINK
YOU'VE GOT TO HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE AND WHAT I MEAN BY
THAT IS GOT TO HIRE PEOPLE FROM
THE NEIGHBORHOOD TO WORK AT THAT
LIBRARY, THEY GOT TO HIRE PEOPLE
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD TO BUILD
THAT LIBRARY.
>> Sean: THIS IS THE THING,
LEO.
WE WANT MONEY INVESTED, MONEY
CREATES, YOU KNOW, CONSTRUCTION
JOBS, IT CREATES FULL-TIME JOBS,
THE OBAMA LIBRARY, PEOPLE THAT
WORK AND GIVE TOURS AND
CONCESSION STAND PEOPLE -- I
DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU HAVE AT A
LIBRARY, I'VE BEEN TO THE REAGAN
LIBRARY, THE NIXON LIBRARY, I
LIKE THEM.
WHY WOULDN'T THEY WANT THAT AND
THINK THAT'S A GOOD THING?
>> LET ME BE AS CLEAR AS I CAN
AND EXPLAIN TO THE VIEWERS.
THIS IS AN ULTIMATE ACT OF
SELFISHNESS ON THE PART OF THE
OBAMA'S.
LIBRARIES ARE CALLED
$550 MILLION.
YOU REALLY WENT ALL THE PEOPLE
OF COLOR, PEOPLE WHO LOOK LIKE
HIM, BUILD THAT LIBRARY AND THE
POOREST AREA OF CHICAGO, THE
BLACK AREA, FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPING.
DOES HE DO THAT?
NO, NO, NO.
HE GOES TO THE LAKEFRONT.
HE TAKES THE NICEST PART OF THE
BLACK AREA AND HE WANTS TO
DESTROY THAT.
THE LAKEFRONT, WHY WON'T HE
BUILD IT IN THE INNER CITY?
THIS IS THE MAN WHO IS HIS COLOR
TO BASICALLY DOWNPLAY THE
CRITICISM.
ENVIRONMENTALISTS AND ACTIVISTS
ARE SAYING DON'T BUILD IT HERE,
BUILD IT IN CHICAGO, IN A
SOUTHSIDE WHERE PEOPLE OF COLOR
ARE HURTING.
HE'S NOT LISTENING TO THEM.
HE IS MORE THAN A LAND BARREN
AND HE'S USING --
>> Sean: I'M GOING TO TELL YOU
ONE OF MY BIGGEST CRITICISMS.
ALL THROUGH THE OBAMA YEARS,
HERSCHEL WALKER, THIS IS THE
ONLY SHOW, WE WOULD SCROLL THE
NAMES OF ALL THE PEOPLE THAT
NOBODY HEARS THEIR NAMES, THE
PEOPLE SHOT, THE PEOPLE SHOT AND
KILLED.
NOBODY PAID ATTENTION.
NOBODY CARES.
HIS GEORGE FLOYD IMPORTANCE?
YES, BUT EVERY SINGLE PERSON
SHOT AND KILLED IN CHICAGO EVERY
WEEKEND, THEY ARE IMPORTANT TOO.
AND I'VE BEEN DOING THIS SINCE
2009 ON THIS PROGRAM, AND NOBODY
EVER LIFTS A FINGER, AND EVERY
WEEKEND ANOTHER 50 PEOPLE SHOT,
ANOTHER 12 PEOPLE DROPPED --
KILLED IN A SHOOTING.
>> YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE THINGS,
SEAN, AND I'M GOING TO DISAGREE
WITH LEO JUST A LITTLE BIT,
BECAUSE I LOVE LEO, HE'S MY
BROTHER, BUT I SAY --
>> Sean: ONE OF MY, CHOPPED
LIVER?
WAIT A MINUTE.
>> NO, NO.
NO, NO, SEAN.
BUT WHAT I'M GOING TO SAY HERE
REAL QUICK IS I THINK YOU CAN
EMPOWER THIS COMMUNITY HOW
LITTLE BIT.
AT THE SAME TIME I THINK PEOPLE
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT LAW AND
ORDER.
I THINK HAVE TO EMPOWER THE
COMMUNITY BUT YOU'RE ALSO GOING
TO HAVE POLICING THAT'S GOT TO
COME INTO THAT AS WELL, SO NOW
YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE POLICING
THAT'S GOING TO BE PAYING MORE
MONEY AND THAT'S WHAT I WAS
TALKING ABOUT EARLIER.
HAS ANYONE EVER TALKED ABOUT
WHAT MAYOR LIGHTFOOT DECIDED
THAT, YOU KNOW, DEFUNDING THE
POLICE DIDN'T WORK, THAT NOW I
GOT TO DEFUND THE POLICE, THAT'S
WHAT WE NEED TO BE TALKING
ABOUT, NOT WORRIED ABOUT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS, THE LIBRARY
THAT CAN ALSO HELP PEOPLE.
>> Sean: AT THE END OF THE
DAY, IF YOU DON'T HAVE LAW AND
ORDER AND SAFETY AND SECURITY,
YOU CAN'T PURSUE HAPPINESS.
BY THE WAY, LEO, SUPPORTING HER
CANDIDACY A